foreign
there's one more over here get that one
that's for you thank you sir yeah so and
yeah yeah single picture oh look at that
oh
month so since I'm feeling like Murphy
Brown the chair of points representative
Murphy is our clerk this month you're
welcome
we have as our first order of business
representative Edwards who's in a much
warmer State than New Hampshire
presently his uh minutes from the
meeting of the 28th of October you
should have all gotten these ahead of
time is there anything that you wish to
foreign
anybody
[Music]
representative excuse me Senator gray
moves to approve the minutes
is our second
Kentucky representative Solway any
further discussion
all in favor
aye opposed
so ordered thank you one extension
version
I listen to the guy that was not at the
meeting so abstains from voting thank
you
in our September meeting we appointed a
subcommittee
on the New Hampshire Board of Medicine
transparency
that subcommittee met three times in
October
out of that has come
a report you all got it it looks like
this yes
excuse me would you like to have a roll
we don't need it we don't need it just
write down who's here and who's not
thank you
um
you've all gotten this ahead of time
this is the report it gives the
background to the Board of Medicine it
gives to the the background as to why
this subcommittee came into being chair
wishes to thank representative Solway
and
the subcommittee presents this to
oversight committee for your
foreign
there are copies of the report over
there somewhere and representative
Edwards is selling copies for a dollar
each
excuse me representative will uh excuse
me councilor Williams
and uh chairman Pearson uh members have
received them so if you look for your
packet with the header and represent
Pearson if you just would alert them at
who where it starts they'll be able to
identify that document thank you thank
you
Senator Guida thank you Mr chair
uh
understanding that this is all about
transparency and Public Safety
um
as I Look to page two
the first complete paragraph
where the second sentence says this
would include non-voluntary license or
privileged verifications or suspensions
in any malpractice suits found in favor
of the plaintiff over the past 10 years
it's all well and good that it doesn't
preclude the possibility that a provider
May voluntarily a provider who has
caused harm
May voluntarily
surrender the license for a period of
time
without
you know invoking any kind of um inquiry
and so that to me not that I in any way
shape or form and and disparaging the
practice of medicine or those who do it
but it is a liability within the
existing law and and so I already said
but then they had proposed um uh law and
I think it's something that the
committee should address
yeah
representative Solway sorry
I think that a good Senator has made a
very insightful point that there is a
potential unintended consequence in the
word in the wording in that
um
those who would otherwise be subject
to disciplinary action may be encouraged
to voluntarily
relinquish their privileges
and that would not be reported to the
Board of Medicine as Senator Guida has
pointed out
and we need to be careful perhaps simply
to remove the word non-voluntary
from the wording so that that unintended
consequence does not occur in addition
if I may go on for just a moment Mr
chairman I think we need a motion to
accept
this report and I'd like to enter that
motion to accept the report second and
seconded by Senator guide and now we may
discuss and the report that we have
received we may choose to amend the
reports which will be then a document of
this oversight committee so page two
full paragraph one second sentence you
are suggesting striking the word
non-voluntary yes
yeah any thoughts about that
having served on that subcommittee I
Senator Gaia just looking at wording
he's saying
would you turn your mic on please thank
you Mr chair
so we're not talking about a revocation
or a suspension
so we might want to say a surrender a
voluntary surrender
adding that wording because I don't
think technically if a person's
voluntarily surrenders a license that
it's a revocation or suspension it's
non-disciplinary
foreign
sentence would Now read this would
include license or privilege revocations
or suspensions or surrendering of
any other suggestions on the report uh
Mr chairman representative Solway as per
suggesting that you made uh by email uh
in the first wording it says pursuant to
which the liberations of three October
2020 this is top of the first page yes
we might add three October uh 17 October
and 31 October thank you
that was your idea because we did meet
just remember this is a report that will
be a document of this committee
there is a a draft LSR on this matter
that will follow as our next item of
business that's where some of us will
Trot over to OLS after this meeting is
foreign
Mr chairman and I would suggest that the
motion now be uh moved to accept the
report as amended as amended with that
sentence on page two full paragraph one
second sentence this would include
license or privilege revocations or
suspensions or surrendering of license
and any malpractice suits found in favor
of the plaintiff over the past 10 years
on page one at the very top pursuant to
its deliberations of October 3 17 and
31. that are that's the amendments
anything further before the question is
called
saying nothing
um
would the clerk call the roll on this
representative Ed um soloway
hi
representative Nelson yeah okay yes
Senator Gray
yes
Senator Gaia yes
[Music]
Senator representative McMahon yes
following right along is a draft LSR
to establish a standing commission
regarding oversight of the New Hampshire
Board of Medicine
I had asked representative Solway to
such a document I was working on such a
document
yesterday afternoon I got to see his
they're pretty darn similar
which doesn't necessarily mean great
minds think alike but for the purpose of
this meeting I'd like to think that so
this is to establish a standing
Commission on Board of Medicine
oversight and is composed of
two members of the House
I already have a suggested change here
oh it's here I put it in a member of the
Senate a physician appointed by the
medical society the president of the
Board of Medicine or designee a member
of the New Hampshire Nurses Association
president of New Hampshire Hospital
Association of designate a lawyer
experience with malpractice rules and
procedures appointed by the Attorney
General the executive director of oplc
or designee the president of the New
Hampshire osteopathic Association or
designee a medical ethics ethicist to be
named by the one who will be named chair
a trial lawyer for the plaintiffs and a
trial lawyer for the defense
everybody we need
and indeed it's pretty similar to the
ones who testified on those three days
in October
the
intent and scope I representative Solway
would you take it from here on explain
page two since this is mostly your
wording
um
I believe I have the correct document
but no I
page two of the document in question for
the
LSR starts with intense scope and
Provisions I don't have that Mr chairman
I'm sorry through all this pile of
papers I've been searching through it
and I do not have it yet in front of me
one is about to one one is about to be
thank you I'm sorry for that
and do we have some for them too yeah
when you get it you will see that um
I've been asked to be no this is a
report not the election no we need the
we need something that starts with draft
LSR
the last page is a 10. okay
ah aha
that's weird ah
the um
purpose of the LSR is to create a
commission of oversight
for the Board of Medicine
the intent is to bring together the
stakeholders
in the board of medicines procedures
um to offer uh wisdom and insight into
the efficacy of those procedures and to
make recommendations to the oversight
committee uh of the joint legislature uh
as to the need for any uh regulatory
legislation that may be required
this
is designed to bring together
all of the stakeholders in conference to
give everybody a voice
uh including the public
and to
thereby provide the needed legislative
oversight that the Board of Medicine
if you would read through that second
I'm not offering this as uh to be under
consideration for a vote in the
committee
um
I'm showing
a possible LSR
and
will be soliciting
returning members
um to come on as co-sponsors we'll go
find a few more as well
but if you would like to be a co-sponsor
but there's one or two points you wish
to make ahead of time this would be the
time to do it
those of you who are not returning feel
foreign
coming up with an LSR that would
specifically mandate changes we would
come up instead with an oversight board
who would work with the Bureau of
medicine
um
to look at all of these things
collectively and the reason is we did
our work in a month
and I think a lot of wonderful things
were done but something that's put
together that fast you come to regret we
should have added this we shouldn't have
put that in there so I pulled back and I
know you did two representative from
actually mandating some changes
in an LSR but instead come up with this
oversight committee that would work on
things collaboratively and then make
some suggestions to the legislature for
the future that was that's how this
fully understanding the import of what
this is going to do
I am not a believer in commissions
because
conflicting interests potentially
can side rail a proposal
I'm a much stronger believer in
legislative committees
to which all interested parties are
invited
okay and present their testimony as to
the efficacy or non-efficacy of a
particular proposal
and allow those elected by the people of
the state
okay to be the stewards of their safety
to make the final decision remembering
that it has to go through the
legislative process
all right so my suggestion would be
um a committee comprised of senators and
representatives
to here okay
proposals on legislation from the
various members of this
but I'm I'm I just believe that there's
a possibility of conflict of conflict
when it comes to an interest group that
might not see things the same way for
its own self-interest
not saying it couldn't happen that it
does happen but saying it could happen
and thereby in fact Stonewall or delay
or in fact prevent
putting forth the changes that might
this commission as this draft LSR
outlines it would not preclude the fact
that any legislators could file
legislation
whether they are
legislative members of the commission or
not they could they could still do that
um
I was
very pleased
as we did our business as a subcommittee
how much Unity I heard from all the
stakeholders including the plaintiff and
defense malpractice lawyers we were all
really kind of looking for the same
thing to protect good doctors and
hospitals and Facilities from frivolous
charges
but also to protect the public from the
rare bad actor we all wanted the same
thing and we were pretty darn close as
we were talking as to how we could go
about making that happen better so I
don't personally I don't fear this
commission doing that and should they
um
any legislator can always say a pox on
you I'm going to file a bill
response if that legislator has access
to the information regarding the
well I would think the commission
meetings would be open and Good Records
would be kept and work product would be
seen and if somebody even from the
get-go thinks this commission may not
quite be the way to go
they could come to our meetings
follow-up
yeah I'm not certain what effect HIPAA
has on the presentation of information
about a specific case
so the meetings may not be able to be
open
uh for that if I understand HIPAA that
protects the patient it does not
necessarily protect a professional from
Bad action the name or names of people
who allegedly were harmed would not be
mentioned
you wish follow-up no that's my point
okay representative Solway uh thank you
Mr chairman
um I believe that Senator Guida makes a
very good point that commissions may
very well in fact get gridlocked in
conflicting opinions and I agree with
him also that it is a responsibility of
the legislature and it's duly elected
representatives
to safeguard the well-being of the
people in addition to Physicians
hospitals and so forth I think the
process by which we can refine uh this
LSR is the amendment process
uh once filed and submitted to committee
this is subject to Amendment
and I think the guiding document is the
report which uh the senator and I agree
uh needed to be amended we have done so
and if we set that out as the initial
document to guide a committee or
commission we can file this LSR and
leave it to a committee on Health Human
Services and aging and elderly Affairs
to exercise its wisdom as the
foreign
s that made us a bit comfortable even
though we had to get all our work done
on this and on the next one we're going
to deal with is that although we had a
month to do this uh there will be a
month and a half to two months
to bring forth amendments on this I was
counting on that
so anything else
anybody okay
anybody who's returning who wants in on
the co-sponsorship
who can say that now or
once the once this is filed please let
me know
yeah you're already in there
thank you yeah you served on the
next item is the task force on Precision
medicine and biomarker testing
submission of task force we've got a a
report that
um
representative Solway who chaired this
is going to present to us followed by a
draft LSR and representative Solway
would you make your presentation please
yes
um I I must say ladies and gentlemen Mr
chairman uh I thank you and I must point
out that this was a wonderful
educational opportunity for members of
the subcommittee and I am so grateful to
Representatives Gary Woods
Representatives uh Gary Merchant
representative Jerry Cannon
representative Betty gay and
um obviously
counselor Williams
um
and other members of the committee for
everything that we learned in the
process of putting this together the
draft report is before you originally
this was a motion submitted by uh
representative Catherine Rogers of
blessed memory
who herself was suffering from
um a debilitating disease and who had
benefited in ways from
um Precision medicine and biomarker
testing it was her desire that the
committee on Health Human Services and
elderly Affairs
submit legislation that would establish
a commission to further Precision
medicine and biomarker testing within
the state of New Hampshire
as admirable and intent as that was
our professional members on the
subcommittee
representatives woods and Merchant in
particular
alerted the subcommittee to the fact
that biomarker testing was a um
was a medical technology procedure that
had great promise and was being tested
but that the concept of precision
medicine
and its outcome for people who were
disease had not been proven it had not
been clinically demonstrated and it was
their recommendation and dare I say
their wisdom that the subcommittee could
in fact encourage the establishment of a
commission on biomarkers but that the
overall concept of precision medicine
needed to wait for further testing and
approvals as a result of that the
committee has suggested a rather
different approach and that is the
establishment of a forgive me Senator
Guida a commission on emerging medical
Technologies
giving us a tool to assess new medical
Technologies on a continuing basis and
to determine what the effect of those
emerging medical Technologies
um might be on the cost for example to
Medicaid
we have Mr lippman here with us director
of Medicaid who may or may not wish to
speak to that issue but his
representative on the committee was
quite informative on the fact that these
are very expensive procedures and we
need to take a look at that we needed to
take a look at who was innovating where
the Innovations were coming from whether
they were academic whether they were
entrepreneurial
what the risks might be to our patient
population and so
the subcommittee suggested that we
establish establish
an ongoing Commission on emerging
medical Technologies and that is covered
uh to in my deathless prose uh on the
report
which I'm now submitting to uh the
oversight committee and uh then we have
a draft LSR that will accompany so
um Mr chairman I would like to move the
acceptance of the report to the
oversight committee with regard to
Senator Guida seconds
yes representative Nelson
Mr Cameron where did the FED fed sit in
this has this already been done
um this type of testing to show that the
results were were good and it's really
working on a federal level where there
would be a wider testing procedure uh uh
thank you representative that's an
excellent question
um and
um our representative who came to us
from the Medicaid office went over with
us what the Federal Regulations look
like in terms of what State Medicaid can
support or not support typically we rely
on the FDA the federal Food and Drug
Administration to determine what uh
technologies have been proven and what
have not and
we assume representative
that they act in a good faith and with
due regard for the principles of science
uh with out any other interests imposing
Senator Guida thank you Mr chair
um I want to key on representative
soloway's remarks about commission
versus committee
and I I think he highlighted it this
commission okay none of the members of
this commission would be subject
potentially to punitive action or
litigation because of their actions with
respect to the previous item on the
agenda that's not the case I'd just like
to make that point
any further comments on the report of
the subcommittee
on Precision medicine again thank you so
offer an amendment or two on the first
page
the report as given does not list all of
I believe sir that that was amended
appropriately
how so
who did I miss you mentioned
representative Jerry Cannon and
representative Betty gay in your opening
oh yes and I did submit
um
representative Canon as well and
representative you must have a newer
version then
there were four as I recall
I have it on mine sir
oh good thank you is that your copy or
do you have another one well no I mean
I'll get another one and I can only
assure you sir that representative gay
made a phone call in which he pointed
out those omissions quite directly after
which the changes were made
also
um
I would ask the correct spelling of
Representative Roger's first name that
has also been changed sir
uh not on the most recent Edition I just
got
um
sir I was not a liberal arts major
k-a-t-h-e-r-i-n-e I believe it I believe
so but that's not what I have here that
was supposed to have been changed it may
appear elsewhere and have been changed
elsewhere
and I know I made at least one change
I think since we will be
archiving this as part of our committee
also on
page two at least on my copy everywhere
k-a-t-h-e-r-i-natural okay good good
good and so Mr Clark in whatever Edition
you're archiving uh it needs to be up to
that
all right seeing no further corrections
to the report we have a motion before us
made by representative Solway and
seconded by Senator Guida that we
receive the report of the sub committee
on Precision medicine and biomarkers
all in favor
I opposed that looks like
7-Zip okay good thank you now let's go
to the draft LSR which should be stapled
I'm learning to the report
um
foreign
but you want to go to draft LSR where it
and again Catherine yes
spelled correctly
yes
I was asked to be co-sponsor or prime
sponsor on this because representative
soloway is breaking my heart he didn't
also um if you go down near to the
bottom where it's lowercase G the New
Hampshire Cancer Society will not be
sending a representative because there
is no New Hampshire Society it's the
that change has been made in a later
Edition
okay
are there other changes that have been
made in later editions because I'm I've
got to walk something down to
um OLS and I want to make sure I have
the most up-to-date addition that should
be it sir okay
so take a minute folks everybody and
read it if you haven't already
foreign
suggestions that you would want to make
before this is filed as legislation and
if there's any other members of the
committee and that would include the
clerk and representative McMahon and
Senator gray if any of you wish to be
co-sponsors of this let me know either
Senator gray in the Senate the fastest
way to get on that committee is to
co-sponsor yeah so if you don't have
time
is that a statement of willingness
or unwillingness
I think it's a statement of fact
thank you have you ever considered a
career in politics
I think I'm living it living it got it
anyone else with any comments on this um
then
thank you representative soloway for all
the hard work you did on this as well as
well as the other members of
the emerging medical Technologies
um
thank you
the DHHS Commissioners updates
my statute must be given by a person
whose first name is Laurie is that true
for you
representative lippman how's the name
good afternoon
Lori Weaver Deputy Commissioner
Department of Health and Human Services
uh we agreed I believe
um
throughout the last couple of months to
keep giving updates on Hampstead
Hospital and how that was going
um as many of you know we acquired the
hospital back in June and have been up
and running and hiring staff and trying
to get up to full capacity and we give a
little bit of a snippet each time this
time I'm really pleased to be able to
introduce to you our key leadership
positions uh Kathy Collins and Steve if
you guys want you have to come up yeah
they're going to come up to do a little
bit more of a formal presentation for
you and Marissa hen is handing out the
packets right now sort of a high level
overview of what's been going on at
Hanson hospital since June and Steve
I'll use it here
foreign
good afternoon I'm Kathy Collins I'm the
CEO of Hampstead Hospital and
good afternoon I'm Steve Finnegan I'm
the CEO of Hampstead Hospital and
I wanted to thank you for the
opportunity to be able to give an update
um here we're very excited about all of
the work that we've been doing at
Hampstead
um and continue to do so we'd love to
share all of that great information and
give you that update
um you'll see in the packet on our first
page
um that is our grounds Hampstead
Hospital
um was there since 1974 and we do have a
hundred acres of property there and this
picture does not necessarily do it
justice there is a lot of opportunity
for our patients to have space within
the facility as well as outside open air
space swing sets things of those nature
that actually make it a little bit more
conducive for them to be able to have an
environment for treatment that's geared
more towards children and adolescents
and young adults
and so as Deputy Commissioner
said the hospital was acquired by the
state in June of this year
and since that time
we also have been collaborating with the
well path Recovery Solutions team the
hospital is owned and operated we have
our rest of our leadership team here
with us as well today and their names
are are on our in the presentation as
well
this these are all Department of Health
and Human Services employees that are
overseeing the contract for wellpath and
so wellpath is providing the services
and maintenance of the facility
in the clinical Realm
and the other members of our executive
leadership team we do have
um Representatives as well from the well
path side that join in us to collaborate
to be able to provide the best quality
care that we had been previously doing
and continue to do but with under this
new contract system the executive
director on the well path side was the
long-standing chief nursing operator
that I worked with for decades there so
the vision continues which is aligned
very much with the state's vision for
the services that we're able to provide
we are operating our units we have one
young adult unit
which takes care of patients that are
older adolescents 17 up through age 25
depending on their presentations
um the other three units are A variation
and spend the majority of their days
focusing on ages four up through around
11 12 and then another unit houses
ages 13 14 up through 18 and then our
third children's unit
uh also handles taking care of patients
that have developmental disabilities as
well as
more significant behavioral health
challenges
so one of the things that we actually
had done as an executive team is we
actually had broadened the scope and
looked at our new mission and vision and
values
since being acquired by the state and
really aligning those things and really
looking and taking into consideration
the 10-year mental health plan as well
as collaborating within the system of
care
throughout the state and really aligning
our mission and vision to work with
those things as well so our new mission
statement you have is to provide
trauma-informed patient and family
centered mental health treatment in an
accepting and supporting environment
um and then our vision is to really be
that Center of Excellence for mental
health treatment for children youth and
young adults and adolescents
and that is really truly what we are all
about
um at Hampstead
um like I said we did bring our team
because we think it's important for you
all to see
um the rest of us that are that are all
here on behalf of the state taking care
so right now we're actually
um working with in collaboration with uh
wellpath to increase the bed capacity at
Hampstead currently we're able to have
an average daily census of 37 patients
and with those efforts we're looking to
increase those that bed capacity so that
we would no longer hopefully have a wait
list of patients in the Eds
our current average wait list is around
13 patients per day
um
with the workforce challenges we
actually have
um been able to secure different models
of programming
um we've been offering patients partial
hospitalization when we're not able to
have them full inpatient if that works
for them as well so there are different
um
challenges that we've been working with
the team and the rest of the system of
care throughout New Hampshire
namely with dcyf and also with the
division of Behavioral Health
this is something that's been very
exciting for us be to be able to be part
of that system of care we work very
closely
um with them we have a long-standing
relationship with the state through our
previous contract but in addition to
that we've really been working closely
to assist to care for the patients
that are in need of different levels of
care so we meet regularly
weekly actually more if needed to go
over
different cases that are presenting that
may potentially go to a different
facility or may need a different level
of care to really look at those
individuals and find the best place for
them to be within the state and be able
to get them into an appropriate setting
for the level of care that they need
um
our parents and patient satisfaction
scores are at 90 percent
um satisfaction and we are very proud of
that and we strive to be able to have
that reach 100 someday
um and as well the other
um interesting piece for us is that we
are very proud of our readmission rates
they are very low
they're currently at five percent for 30
and I'm going to hand it over to Steve
good afternoon thank you uh very much
for allowing us to be able to talk to
you today about the important and uh
really great work that our teams uh at
Hempstead Hospital are doing uh what
you'll see on the next graph is really
uh a summation of our daily averages
that we're you know accepting and
discharging
um so what you can see here I think is
is truly
um an understanding that we're
essentially getting the same amount of
patients in that we're discharging and
ultimately our goal as a team is to
increase that our goal is to take
as many patients as we possibly can with
the ability that we have and currently
as we'll talk about on the next slide
some of the barriers to those are are
our staffing models right now and and
the ability to get increased Staffing in
that in the complexity of patients that
we're taking
um there there's a level of complexity
in the patients that we take that really
require
a lot of work and so those have been
some of our uh our our challenges in a
way of of taking in and discharging some
of those patients
um but again we continue to strive to
increase those numbers and I think as
you can see uh month over month where
we're we're doing uh we are doing that
um on the next side you'll see our
staffing positions
um and so I'm sure
um as we all
um look at Staffing positions across
many Industries uh Healthcare uh has has
really been hurt by uh by Staffing and
what you see here is is that our
executive team truly identified a couple
of the key positions that we needed here
at the hospital in order to really truly
take care of our patients and and those
would be nurses and counselors and so we
did work with our our well path partners
and the contractor in order to truly
identify identify unique ways and out of
the box ways and thinking of of getting
those Staffing numbers up and as you'll
see
um you know we're pretty proud of where
we're at particularly on the nursing
side we went from about a 61 percent
filled rate to right now or about 82
percent filled uh in our nursing
positions which is which is really great
that provides us the opportunity to
truly care for these patients we're
continuing
um to work on the counselor positions
those are a little bit more uh
challenging to to fill but we are
looking at all all ways of of trying to
attract those positions and and again
we feel very confident that we'll be
able to do that and that will allow us
to continue to to take more children and
to
provide that high level of care one of
the great things that I I think uh is
worth noting you know truly is our
ability since uh being a state entity at
this point is
um our ability to work collaboratively
across
um Health and Human Services and with
our partners to truly understand that
we're taking more complex patients but
but how we're taking those patients and
their their the care that they're having
both before they get to us and truly
strategizing and collaborating on that
care that those children and the
services those children will get after
they leave us
um that you know I think it's really
important
um as we continue to tell ourselves and
our teams that you know these patients
um their care doesn't stop just with us
right it's that collaboration and that
and that care that goes beyond well
beyond what happens after they leave our
doors
we do you often meet with our external
partners and it's something that I find
both very rewarding and I to me gives
our teams the ability to truly have a
more comprehensive strategic approach to
taking care of our kids
um
and you know I think another big piece
of what we are trying to do here at
Hampstead Hospital is is not only look
at the the level of treatment and care
that we're giving our children today but
but also looking at 2023 and Beyond what
are we doing now and how can we continue
to provide this level of care and and I
think you know as Kathy alluded to you
know the 10-year mental health plan that
was developed
by a lot of you
really sets the tone and gives us sort
of a guiding path as to how we want to
continue to move forward uh to care for
those children in New Hampshire
one of the things that we're very proud
of is our psychiatric residential
treatment facility which will be opening
up hopefully by the end of the first
quarter in 2023 this will be the first
type of this facility in New England
typically right now we you know we these
these type of patients
we're not able to care for here in New
Hampshire and so our ability to bring
these kids back home so that they can
develop and get that treatment here not
only with the support of our teams but
the support of their families and and
state resources I think uh is is really
really important
one of the other things that I think is
equally as important to both attracting
uh attracting folks to come work for uh
Hempstead hospital but also retaining
the folks we have is really developing
that culture and we are working with our
external Partners we have you know great
guidance from our leadership at HHS as
well as our collaborative partners with
New Hampshire hospital to truly
understand what it is to be you know a
state run facility and how we as a
state-run facility want to
want to truly be delivering that level
of care and so um I I think it's
something that we are constantly
retooling but but also find as a a
critical component to our successes
really setting that culture and ensuring
that that folks want want to be there
and like like the work that they're
doing and then lastly I I think we're
always again as our future focused is
that we are starting and preparing to
launch the procurement process of our
longer term longer term excuse me
clinical contract and so as we continue
to develop our processes for today we
are looking at the long term and and
really trying to better understand and
prepare and strategize as to how uh and
what Hampstead Hospital and residential
treatment facility looks like uh in in
thank you Senator guided with a question
thank you Mr chair actually I have
several with your Indulgence let's try
two and we'll come back okay
um the wait list averages 13 a day
where are they kept and how for how long
do you have an average time that they're
right
so typically our
the patients are at the emergency room
in the emergency department and if they
are at the emergency room the average
time they are triaged the patients and
they actually for a high level triage
they are typically it is roughly four to
six days that they're waiting
thank you
second question
so
it's distressing to see the low the the
low level of counselors that you have
I'm sure you're working very hard in it
can you attribute that to any factors
obviously every Healthcare facility is
struggling but that seems
uh yeah so I I think there are multiple
factors in that in that
um one of the things we've identified
through
um the contract was that well path
originally was was uh recruiting under
the the well path name and what we found
was well well path although is a
national company wasn't necessarily
recognized in this area
um and a lot of folks didn't you know
had trouble sort of getting to that
website and really applying for
positions and so working with the well
path team we really kind of identified
that as you know one we have to really
look beyond the the way that they were
in the the job postings that they were
putting out number two we really wanted
to put the Hampstead Hospital you know
logo out there right because it's
recognizable to the community
um and we looked and
um you know through some research we
found that you know LinkedIn jobs is is
uh where a lot of hospitals today are
hiring from so we really wanted to make
sure that wellpath was utilizing those
type of resources as best as possible
you know where we're
continuing to to try to find unique ways
of getting folks in right and making
sure that they're the right folks right
and making sure that their
qualifications sort of hit where we want
that will be the best providing for our
for our teams and so
um I think this is continual will
continue to be an uphill battle but
um I I've seen much more success over
the last you know couple of months than
um how he how he started thank you
anyone else representative Nelson
thank you thank you Mr chairman just
curious as to the nurses and counselors
how many of the counselors are full-time
versus part-time and
so the uh counselors are on duty there's
nursing and counseling staff on 24 hours
a day
um and it varies with the number of
counselors and if you look at the number
of counselors It's it's skewed a little
bit by the fact that there are many more
counselors on a day-to-day basis than
there are nurses so the the occupancy is
of that rate is is a little deceiving
um the number of full-time counselors I
don't have the exact number but I can
tell you that most of them are full-time
we used to have a very lengthy per diem
pool which has subsequently gone by the
wayside and we are only down to about
five or six per diem staff right now so
most of those are full-time employees
right now
yes Minecraft follow-up and that number
of people full-time would be
approximately
um about uh I think it is around
85. 85 yeah
and what number of people are there
seven counselors or full-time or three
or no no we're talking about 85 ftes and
one FTE would each equal 40 hours so
okay
representative Murphy thank you I'm just
curious as to the average length of stay
and when discharged where do the
patients go typically
yeah so that's a it's a fantastic
question so
um our our typical average length of
stay obviously a lot depends on
um the the Acuity of those patients and
uh I'm going to answer your second
question first and that um part of what
part of the resources that we've had
since being becoming a state-run
facility is that we have that
collaborative approach with
um external resources like dcyf
um and and the Behavioral Health
Services which really help
um help us understand where these kids
are going to go next right A lot of them
go to residential treatment facilities
and and others are discharged back home
um with with resources in the community
that will help those kids
um and so you know every every patient
is a little bit different
um and you know each patient has sort of
a different care plan that that allows
for their the best outcome for them in
the long term right our goal truly is to
make sure that they are once they leave
the hospital that they they don't
necessarily have to come back right and
so providing them those those type of
skills from a length of State
perspective
um you know our our our patients
typically
um
you know are are here right around seven
to ten days right and and it again a lot
of it depends on what they're coming in
for that real acute level of care
um but but a lot of times
that can vary right with with based on
where they're going after right and and
how you know getting into the
residential facilities
um there's often as we talk about uh
Staffing challenges Right There Staffing
challenges there as well and so that can
at times cause some challenges of
getting those those kids to the place in
an appropriate amount of time
um but again this is really truly where
the collaboration comes in and making
sure that we have uh a plan of
understanding of what we're doing for
those kids while they're still in our
our care and then what the true truly
what the timeline is for them to get
follow up in um is there any type of
patient diagnosis that you do not take
um mental health diagnoses that you
I'm sure there probably would be one out
there if I said there was absolutely
none but I cannot think of anything that
we currently cannot treat
um with the
exception of any type of forensic truly
forensic child and we are only a drf up
through age 17 so anybody that's not
voluntary Beyond age 17 18 and up great
you use the term nurse and
is there a breakdown between
RNs and LPNs and some of the newer
qualifications of Nursing
so we recently that was part of the
strategies as well
um so we are joint commission accredited
and we require to have a nurse an RN on
each unit each shift that has to be
solely designated for that unit
we previously had had LPNs in the past
so we decided to start looking at
utilizing LPNs to provide support for
the RNs and that actually attributes we
now have three LPNs total out of all of
our RNs that our LPNs that work side by
side with the nurses but they typically
tend to count in under the counselor
ratio because of the limitations of
their licensure
I know that some facilities in the state
and I think
the nursing home in Rockingham County
being one of them realizes there's such
a shortage that they're bringing in
people to train them on the job while
they're there in other words where three
of my aunts went a Hospital School of
Nursing yes yes
is that something possibly in the future
here
you never know I mean we would love to
see and see something like that I mean
we do have several schools that we have
come through with the nursing students
and I can tell you that that is a a very
big boon with getting them to come back
if you like children and you're
interested in in Psych then coming and
doing your rotation there oftentimes
they will come back and work for us we
also do the same thing with social
workers and we have a Residency program
that is going to be starting in January
of this year for psychiatrists as well
I've done this in my facility of which
I'm a CEO in Kingston and I continue to
like this as a possibility learning on
the job and they give us X number of
years or months working with us and
along the way we we get to know them and
so on sir absolutely I I think in
addition to that one of the things that
we've identified is truly building the
culture right to allow for that that's
right and and absolutely having that
level of commitment from all of our
staff so that those who do come in that
may be learning on the job
um feel that sense of community and
unity there so that it really wants them
to stay and give back and so that's one
of our differentiators we hope in
keeping folks uh here at Hampstead and
and I think that will play a a very
significant role as we move forward
I have a few more questions have has the
security coverage
protocol issue
been worked out because I know there was
one
between Hampstead police and other folks
the uh mou between DHHS and safety has
been signed
and myself and our general counsel has
met with Hampstead Police Department
we've had a very good working
relationship with them as well and
they're also working with us to support
us through the whole the whole process
and they are coming back in a few weeks
for us to continue those discussions
um and just kind of collaboration
good
um
I understand that roughly half of the
payment and lieu of taxes has been made
when can we as a Hampstead taxpayer
expect the second payment
that is not something I have anyone know
the answer coming right up
hi everyone Melissa sancer Chief lead
officer for DHHS how are you
um the second payment will be made when
the when we receive the bill for the
second half which I believe is in
December
the same time I get mine yeah
all right
um who owns the responsibility for
making sure that this will continue in
because they're about to be my next best
friend
um so we are working currently with the
governor's office to have that payment
put into our budget yeah thank you
you're welcome
any other questions for that about that
legal no no
thank you uh would it be possible for a
state representative who lives within
one mile of the facility to swing by and
have a tour please absolutely we welcome
everybody to come in even greater than
one mile absolutely okay I love to show
if you have the requisite staff we're
looking at percentages here if those
numbers went up to a hundred what would
your capacity be
we have the capacity for 70 inpatients
right now
and then there will be those 12 beds for
it's another guy you had some more
questions thank you Mr chair
so looking at the
I call it the incomplete percentages of
your personnel are is the workforce
state employees
they're not they're all employed by well
path right and so are they represented
union union representative or not
they are currently in Union negotiations
Hampstead Outlook
previous owners we had a collective
bargaining agreement with the SEIU and
they're currently negotiating that yep
one question
um
are your pay rates competitive is that
one of the reasons that perhaps you
might not have as many people coming
forth
I don't believe so at this moment
because we have since the beginning
um well path has been very receptive to
increasing the rates that they were very
diligent in their initial
um
research to find the competitive rates
we're not necessarily seeing that that
is the issue and it along the lines of
teaching and having people work for us
most of our counselors that come and
work for us for a few years they're
going they go to school while they're
with us and finish up their degrees and
then move on to other positions and
that's currently what we're seeing it's
the you know that that transition time
so they're moving out into other
positions and social work or nursing and
then we are
not getting The Replacements as quickly
but I will tell you it's very promising
over the last couple of weeks we've
really broadened the scope and looked at
changing up the types of positions and
really looking more towards the
positions like music therapy and art
therapy this as opposed to the counselor
nurse
um
previous compliment that we had had
when we were Hampstead Outlook
I would I would sorry I would also add
that the success that you see in our
nursing increase was a lot due to the
conversations that we had with wellpath
on how do we make it more competitive
and offering bonuses and and aspects
like that we saw that be very successful
and it really targeted we targeted what
we needed in particular overnight nurses
and so we're really starting to
strategize on that and and look at the
financial component of bringing in more
counselors
um and really targeting how we can do
that financially to to attract to for
the positions to be attractive
ready
representative Solway may I make a brief
comment please you may make a brief
comment please
um thank you Ms Collins thank you Mr
Finnegan um I just want to alert uh the
members of the committee and the public
uh to something that I suspect you may
know
um their
um was a member of one of our
departments I believe it was Parks and
Recreation who noted that we're New
Hampshire we're not New York we're not
New Jersey we do things differently and
we take care of one another and the
development of Hampstead Hospital by the
state is really a very good example of
how we try to take care of one another
not necessarily with money on the table
uh so a
senior level person in Parks and
Recreation
um call down to our urban forestry
Center in Portsmouth and you may be
aware the state runs this wonderful
facility in Portsmouth uh it's run by
its director AJ dupare and the person
from Parks and Recreation mentioned that
they had had a child who had been at
Hampstead Hospital
and wouldn't it be nice if the state
just did something wonderful for these
kids so AJ Dupree at the urban forestry
Center will be providing plantings
prunings
walking paths and hiking trails for
Hampstead Hospital no cost no obligation
it's New Hampshire it's how we take care
of one another it's Thanksgiving we need
to be glad that we live here thank you
very very much that's amazing
I may have written this wrong I want to
get it right
we were talking about average length of
stay of 7 to 10 days but it can be
longer and if
where they should go to next is full did
I hear that correctly could you describe
what where they go to next is yeah so
with the average length of stay I would
like to eight
extrapolate a little bit on that so that
is to our typical average length of
state to stabilize a patient is seven to
ten days
um
recently we have actually noticed and we
tracked this
um continually and our average length of
stay has increased because of the
patients not being able to go to the
residential treatment facilities or
group homes
or prtfs which we will then have
um so that's the next steps
the other
contributing factor is being able to
have in-home supports for some of our
patients that don't necessarily meet
criteria for residential treatment but
they may need an in-home therapist
which is provided through external
agencies Community Mental Health Centers
and their Workforce is also struggling
and so we won't send a patient out to
the community until they actually have
those safe resources in place
the facility of which I'm
a part-time CEO is a training site we
get a lot of students coming through and
often if they're on one of their very
early rotations I keep a special eye on
them having been a hospital chaplain at
one point and trained in counseling I
want to see how the students are
handling not one but several patients
per day some of which may trigger
certain things my grandmother died of
that Etc or or or and how are they
coping are they swallowing it are they
going in the ladies room and crying
because if they don't know how to deal
with it
tomorrow's a new day with 12 14 15 more
people and so on and so on so I'm green
on grass especially on our newer
students coming through what intentional
Provisions do you do with new hires
especially if they're young in their
careers
uh well path Recovery Solutions they
actually have are in the process right
now of
completing a training module and a
training program for them currently our
an orientation phase if you will and
they're formalizing that to include that
but historically we have always they
have an immediate milieu supervisor then
they also have a unit director manager
and we have very large Open Door
policies at the hospital where they can
come and talk and walk through in
addition to that we have very
formalized processes for any
incidents that occur anything that's
traumatic if you will in the day-to-day
because that happens in the day-to-day
all the time that there's something that
could be of concern so they meet
together as a team to process the day in
report in the morning and then in the
afternoon on both ends of their shifts
and then there is a formalized process
for them to be able to review specifics
and debrief on any incident that occurs
throughout the day that would be
I would also say and I I really
appreciate the question because I think
again this goes back to culture and I
think one of the things that we're
trying to do and and really our
executive team is is really behind is
developing that sense of uh
understanding that this job is really
difficult in that we want to help grow
our staff and so we've started providing
leadership trainings we've started
providing ways in which we can talk to
our staff
ways in which we can guide our staffs to
develop that next level of leadership
opportunities
and again hope that they stay and grow
within the role we've provided a group
of our team through a presentation a
book on change management right how to
understand and what work through change
because as we all know change happens
every day and it's something that we're
really focused on you know really
identifying the temperature of the
building at all times seeing where there
are some challenges with morale seeing
where there are some challenges with
um with things that we can help control
and then providing that support
from the very very top and making sure
that everybody knows that we as a group
we as Hampstead are really care about
them and care about not only what
they're doing for our patients but but
truly about them as individuals and I
think we've gotten some pretty good
response up to this point uh and I hope
that we can continue to see that success
I came back from spending quite some
time doing debriefing with the New York
fire department after 9 11. and I came
back getting ready to see how my staff
was doing and 10 minutes into a
conversation with one of my counselors I
realized he realized I was showing signs
of secondary PTSD and he was debriefing
me so it can go up the line too yeah
any other questions
thank you so much thank you very much
I'll be giving you a call
look forward to it
foreign
I am never done with you but are you
done with us
I believe so unless you had any other
questions for me
for the Deputy Commissioner Laurie thank
Healthcare Health Care acquired
infections report update Katrina Henson
division of Public Health Services at
DHHS
welcome back thank you hello everyone
good afternoon chairman and members of
the committee my name is Katrina Hansen
I am the chief of infectious disease
surveillance within the Bureau of
Infectious Disease Control division of
Public Health Services and I am here to
provide an update on the healthcare
associate infections program which is a
legislative creative created program and
several reports we have provided this
and reported these data to the committee
for over 10 years so I will only touch
on the data highlights have you given a
handout out I haven't what does it look
like it would be a letter to the
committee and then there are two reports
right behind it
titled Hospital associate infections and
Ambulatory Surgery centers
yes I I think what representative Solway
okay thank you yep uh detailed data are
also available online and I did also
provide two full copies of the reports
as well but they're over 150 pages long
so I only brought one copy each I will
also provide budget and other program
updates
so there are a lot of acronyms in
various terms I will introduce each one
at the first time for clarity but feel
free to ask questions after I can also
clarify and I am also pleased to share
that the reports in front of you we've
released the 13th report on Hospital
associate infections and the 10th report
on Hospital Healthcare Associated
infections and Ambulatory Surgery
centers this week and we are planning to
issue a press release next week
Hospital data hospitals are required to
report central line Associated
bloodstream infections or clab C and
catheter Associated urinary tract
infections in intensive care units or
ICU and surgical site infections or SSI
following certain heart colon knee and
abdominal hysterectomy surgeries
hospitals are also required to report
Healthcare Personnel vaccination rates
overall New Hampshire reported and
observed fewer hais or Healthcare
Associates infections than predicted
based on National Data 157 infections
were reported by hospitals in 2021 which
is 39.4 fewer than predicted based on
National Data
there were fewer infections observed for
central line Associated bloodstream
infections catheter-associated urinary
tract infections and surgical site
infections following Colony colon bypass
and knee replacement procedures when
compared to the predicted number of
infections and these data are considered
lower to National Data abdominal
hysterectomy was statistically
significantly higher than predicted knee
replacement procedures or infections
following those procedures to Central
Line bloodstream infections and catheter
Associated urinary tract infections
though the numbers were low they were
not statistically significant and
considered similar to National Data
Healthcare Personnel influenza
vaccination coverage in hospitals was
89.2 percent which Falls slightly short
of the healthy people 2020 goal of 90
and a decrease from prior years which
really averaged between 90 to 95 percent
in Ambulatory Surgery centers 10 centers
reported surgical site infections
following breast hernia and open
reduction of fracture procedures in
addition Ambulatory Surgery centers also
report compliance on measures put in
place to protect patients
the number of observed infections was
lower compared to national data and
Ambulatory Surgery centers in fact they
reported zero infections of those
procedures for 2021 and they also
reported zero infections in 2020 if that
provides some context in 2019 they
facilities did not report influenza
vaccination and one facility didn't
report surgical site infection following
specified procedures
but compliance measures put in place to
protect patients was high Healthcare
Personnel influenza vaccination in ASCS
was 89.7 percent an increase from the
prior year which is 88 percent in 2020
21 influenza season and the coverage
ranged from 52 percent to 100 percent
adherence to surgical intravenous
antimicrobial prophylaxis has remained
above 96 since these data were first
collected in 2012 and 11 ASCS did not
report that metric
some other program updates I'm pleased
to share that HEI program is almost
fully staffed we have five full-time
staff after 11 months of several
vacancies in 2021 and even with that
Staffing the Hai program conducted 36
investigations of outbreaks infection
control breaches antimicrobial resistant
infections and Drug diversion events
compared to 20 20 22 investigations in
2020. the program has also helped with
investigations and infection prevention
assessments within Health Care settings
pertaining to influenza kova 19
infection control breaches and Drug
diverging events the program is also
working on a new collaborative called
project first line which is a goal has a
goal providing engaging in Innovative
and effective infection control training
to healthcare workers across the
Continuum of Care in 2022 the project
first line lead rolled out a train the
trainer program as well as provided
direct education to healthcare personnel
the program is working on effects
prevention education in correction
settings as well fall in receipt of our
Equity Grant and the program is working
on antimicrobial resistance activities
to coordinate Statewide efforts to
detect and prevent antimicrobial
resistance this also includes developing
a Statewide antibiogram that can be
disseminated to Health Care Providers
throughout the state and in Prior years
we've actually made that of that data
available on the Samford guide app to
make it more accessible and easier for
providers
the program also responds to reports of
carbopenum resistant enterobacteria ACA
or cre which are family of bacteria that
are resistant to a certain type of
antibiotic in 2021 the program
investigated 93 potential cre infections
per RSA 150 134 the department has also
required to report on program costs to
the Health and Human Services committee
regarding the amount of federal funding
received for the program and the amount
of funds paid for by Health Care
Facilities
the program was awarded or the program
operating budget for State fiscal year
2022 was 368
660. and the program was awarded 414 200
through the epidemiology and laboratory
capacity Grant and additionally the HEI
program was awarded two supplemental
grants called sharp and strike the sharp
Grant was 2720 938 to support Hai and
antimicrobial resistance capacity
whereas the strike Grant was to
strengthen and support infectious
prevention infrastructure and long-term
care setting specifically and then 200
000 in Equity Funds which I mentioned
are to help with training and infection
prevention and correction settings
no fees were assessed in state fiscal
year 2022 due to receipt of all these
federal funds including funds support
infrastructure for Hai reporting which
includes those reports that you see in
front of you antimicrobial resistance
infections and educating healthcare
workers
in closing in the coming year we look
forward to continuing to improve and
make our reports more efficient in our
surveillance more efficient and also
specifically the antimicrobial
resistance work and working on
Healthcare System infections in other
settings such as dialysis or end-stage
renal dialysis centers we also will
continue to respond effectively and
efficiently to outbreaks or other events
that compose Public Health harm and then
tracking our program performance working
on important prevention initiatives such
as addressing covid-19 and antimicrobial
resistance drug diversion and ensuring
proper infection controls in healthcare
settings through these infection control
assessments that our program conducts
work to enhance infectious prevention
activities with correction settings that
I mentioned previously and expanding
that training to include officers in
Residence response responsible for
environmental clean and health care
support
and expand on infection prevention
training to emergency medical personnel
including gaps and challenges with drug
diversion reporting as well as
enhancements to retune infection
prevention and response and then lastly
further engage with our HealthCare
Partners and hospitals and Ambulatory
Surgery centers to increase and improve
reporting and the program staff already
have a plan and are providing training
to provide training to those settings
including dialysis to facilitate
inclusion of that report or that data in
a future report
and that's all I have for you today
pending any questions you mentioned that
in terms of the hospitals our numbers
are much better than the national
average that's correct other than the
spectacular job that the hospital
why would you think that is
I think there's many factors
um there's a lot of quality efforts that
are being underway at various Healthcare
facilities the measures we track we've
been tracking for over 10 years and we
have seen improvement over time and we
do see that overall as a whole New
Hampshire has had fewer infections
reported than National Data however if
you look at it year by year our number
there is variability in the number of
infections that are reported and so
there are still things that we can do
and work with facilities to improve
infections going forward my overall goal
is zero or as few infections as possible
there's a lot of mechanisms in place to
prevent infections such as surgical
checklists antimicrobial prophylaxis
tracking various other practice measures
that have Healthcare facilities have put
in place I also know that the infection
prevention-ness and other individuals at
Healthcare facilities work very hard and
diligently every day to not only report
these data but also to ensure that those
Healthcare facilities know those
practices any other questions
representative Murphy thank you um I was
just curious
um only because I've heard of a recent
hospital that showed an increase uh in C
diff
do you monitor that or track it at all
uh and I patients can come into the
hospital with it but they certainly can
acquire it when the hospital so I was
just wondering if in any way you take a
look at those numbers thank you
representative Murphy that's a great
question
um so C diff or clostridium difficile
infection or CDI we also call it is not
a reportable condition under our statue
RSA 151 nor is it a loan under 141c
which is the general public health
reporting for reportable conditions
however if there was a cluster outbreak
or unusual occurrence of disease we
would get alerted to that in 2021 I
don't believe there was any reported
cluster of C diff we also do track we do
track or provide resources around
clusterium difficile during these
infection control assessments and we do
have a special component of that
assessment that does discuss C diff
particularly around the use of antimic
or alcohol-based hand sanitizer in
ensuring that providers are also using
appropriate precautions and also washing
their hands since C difficile is a
really resistant organism But to answer
your question short no we do not track C
difficile good thank you
Senator Guida thank you Mr chairman uh
excellent report some questions how many
fatalities do we have in the state in
the reporting period that is a really
good question and unfortunately I cannot
provide you the answer because we do not
track mortality associated with these
infections and how they are reported
into the system
the system we use called National
Healthcare Safety Network only shows the
number of infections it doesn't show the
mortality associated with it though
certain infections do have higher
mortality associated with them
in particularly central line Associated
bloodstream infections and certain
surgical site infections may have higher
mortality associated with them so those
um those those infections are ones that
we really do track closely to try to
reduce those infections to the best of
our ability so to paraphrase you're not
tracking fatalities that is correct we
are not tracking fatalities you track
re-hospitalizations
and no we do not track hospitalization
or re-hospitalizations to your knowledge
how many states do on both
I don't think I have that answer in
front of me I'll have to bring that back
and come back to you I for at least the
tool that we use many states use the
same tool it's a national based system
there isn't a mechanism in there that
can really get down to that nuanced
level of morbidity or re or
re-hospitalizations or mortality
associated with those infections thank
you Mr I would significantly hope that
someone proposes legislation because my
constituents are not interested in
percentages but there are when I push
the legislation that was brought in by a
new representative 20 years ago 99 New
Hampshire citizens died from hospital
acquired inspections that's data we need
to keep it's not your fault that we're
not it's our fault that we haven't made
that metric a requirement and so I would
certainly ask that somebody on the
stable would you shoot me an email over
the weekend please sure to that effect
and as much as you can and write the
lsr2 for me while you're up wait a
minute I'm retiring no you're not
thank you for any other questions
well representative Solway a comment Mr
chairman uh really for you and I would
invite Miss Henson to respond
um
we are a small state
and we have one academic Medical Center
in the state
we are adjacent to probably the world's
greatest agglomeration of medical
expertise in the world in the city of
Boston and as a result of that
when we here in New Hampshire uh
encounter vulnerable patients when we
get hit by a resistant infection it is
not unlikely that we ship them to Boston
so at the risk of uh tearing a rotator
cuff patting ourselves on the back
we probably not become terribly
comfortable with our data compared to
other states some of that is an artifact
thank you representative that's a good
comment we do struggle with this um
there's a lot of
patients travel across border for
healthcare I think is what you're
referencing alluding to and then also
antimicrobial resistant infections can
then also then spread or really be
undetected
I do want to mention that our program
works diligently when we do identify an
antimicrobial resistant infection that
is within our reportable condition law
we work closely to try to identify the
path of that patient and then where the
various Healthcare touch points were to
ensure that if let's say that a patient
was in Massachusetts or in a Vermont
facility or main facility we will
contact the health department in that
location and try to ensure that if
patients were or Healthcare Providers
may have been exposed that those
individuals are appropriately notified
thank you
representative Nelson did you have a
question no okay just waving okay hi
anyone else thank you so much for your
next up tuition waiver for children and
State foster care or guardianship
attorney Beth mudgeson and
knees so you have a rule in your
division for bets like DHHS does with
Laurie's is that correct that's correct
thank you yes so yes my name is legally
Elizabeth me but you can refer to me as
Beth I'd work for that I didn't mean any
disrespect but that's what it is in the
um before we begin I'd like to thank you
all for performing the roles that you do
on behalf of the citizens of New
Hampshire I applaud the time and effort
you put into the governess of the
Granite State
and have voted personally I have voted
in every election that I've been
entitled to do so so I'm in awe of what
um going back to me personally I was the
first
person in my family
to be awarded a Bachelor of Science in
education
many moons ago
back then
College was
reasonably affordable to working class
middle class Americans
now my entire tuition when I attended
Wheelock College is one year at
unh
um so I just want to put that a little
bit on your radar
my position with DHHS dcyf is in
conjunction with the Adolescent program
as youth engagement specialist
I work with the tuition waiver program I
also
facilitate the youth Advisory Board and
I track the United data which is
National Youth and transition
um I enjoy it immensely
and one of my favorite things is
engaging with these youth that have
applied for the tuition waiver
um and that's part of my job
responsibility is to engage with those
youth
it involves calls texts emails and
fortunately my adult children have also
taught me how to FaceTime quite well so
I use whatever venue I can to reach out
to these youth
um
and I also try to empower them and
include them in any correspondence or
conversation
in addition to their foster parent or
adoptive parents
um
so
let's see
there were 49 certified applicants for
the tuition waiver program this year
by comparison there were 48 applicants
in 2021 and 46 in 2020. so we've seen a
rise in students that would like the
tuition waiver
but there aren't enough to go around at
the time you know right now so we have
to wait list youth
uh
um we're looking to expand eligibility
to the ages of 23 to 26 because not all
kids are ready to go on to college at
18. so we'd like to widen that a little
bit
we are also looking to expand the
criteria for eligibility to include
youths at Exit dcyf care through a
permanency plan of legal guardianship to
a relative or other adult
thank you
we're also looking to increase the
amount of waivers from both the
community college and university of New
Hampshire systems
and we're also looking to expand
eligibility criteria to include youth
placed with grandparents or other
I'm not going to
re-read for you the data included in the
um but I will
refer to
the thank you note that you all got from
Michaela
who is a first year student at nhti
and things like this make me feel like
this program is a worthy one and when
you have a young adult working on a
viable career
and
and I'm a little nervous and I apologize
so are we it's okay
but we don't have to apologize
okay
how we doing do you have questions for
me do we have questions for Elizabeth
AKA Beth
representative Nelson
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question you mentioned foster
parents and somewhere I thought you said
adoptive parents is that adoptive
parents of a foster child or
adoptive parents for a child who's been
in care it been in the system like
Michaela was adopted by
Stephanie stillings and they gave
permission for me to do to present this
to you today so just to clarify one
thank you I have two adopted children
that are grown now so under the system
theoretically they could have gotten
free tuition
tuition assistance yes and under the
circumstances I think yep and and the um
criteria are on the application would
you like me to go through that with you
no sir okay thank you thank you
any further questions
saying none thank you so much for your
report and being with us today
and the final thing on the agenda
a report update
regarding the use of restraints
and the use of different modes of
transportation of patients
for the record my other son many of you
know my eldest son was a State Rep from
Derry my younger son is a corrections
officer at Greenhaven
Maximum Security Prison in New York and
much of what he does is
prison transfers to things so we've had
a good chat on this and he sent me all
kinds of stuff so this is something I'm
quite interested in
great well thank you I'm Ellen Lapointe
I'm the CEO at New Hampshire hospital
thank you for allowing us a moment uh in
today's meeting to present on the New
Hampshire patient transportation and
restraint data report
this is the third iteration of this
report that that has come to this
committee uh and by way of reminder this
was passed and signed into law in July
of 2019 via Senate Bill 177 which
included an explicit option of using
ambulance or law enforcement for
transportation of patients who have been
identified as iea or involuntary
emergency admissions from hospital
emergency departments to New Hampshire
hospital or other designated receiving
facilities
as part of this law is this report that
we are presenting to you today and
present on an annual basis
um and joining me today is Carolyn Lavoy
via New Hampshire Hospital Association
and I want to just take a moment to
thank New Hampshire Hospital Association
for their hard work and partnership in
helping us compile this data and putting
it into this beautiful beautiful report
format that you see today so Carolyn's
going to walk us through the report and
then of course if there's any questions
or I do have a couple of summary points
um at the end so Carolyn take it away
foreign
thank you so much good afternoon Mr
chairman members of the committee thank
you for having me so I will walk through
the report you should have in front of
you which contains summary statistics
from year three which we're calling
which is October of 2021 through
September of 2022 and since we now have
three years of data under our belt we
have some trending statistics to share
as well
so on the bottom of page one
see there are 1271 ieas in this 12-month
period that's an average of 106
transports per month
vast majority of these 99 were adults
um 37 of transports happened by
ambulance 62 by law enforcement and the
rest were by other means
when it came to the use of restraints it
was pretty split there was 46 percent
occurred without restraints 53 with and
we did have a handful of unknowns
and for the transfers that use
restraints it was pretty split between
the use of combination handcuffs only
and um waist belt only
if you turn to the next page
the table at the top takes that 1271
number and it breaks it down by month as
well as the DRM facility that received
the patient
just to give you a sense of volumes New
Hampshire hospital did take a majority
63 percent and the rest were divided
among the other six
the next few sections have some more
detail on these metrics and these are
for adult transports only
so first is the mode of transportation
summary
for adults 62 percent uh through the
year were transported by law enforcement
and as you can see from the bar chart
this didn't fluctuate too much over the
year I ranged between 57 and 66 so not
too much variation on the division of
the Moto transportation
on the following page there's a
breakdown of the restraint application
and this is divided up by the mode of
transportation as well
on the left you see the ambulance counts
there were only four ambulance
transports in through the whole year
that used a restraint law enforcement
was much higher 84 percent total of law
enforcement transports did use
restraints for adults and other
transports is in the third column
um of I believe all of the other
transports that used restraints do refer
to staff at the prison moving their
inmates to a facility
been on page four
you see the breakdown of adult restraint
type used by law enforcement
you can see there is no one method that
was highly preferred again pretty evenly
split between combination handcuffs and
waist belt with a few leg restraint only
and at the bottom of page four we see
the summary for the child transport and
restraints there are only 15 child ieas
through the entire 12-month period seven
were taken by law enforcement eight by
ambulance and that was basically how the
um
the restraint was split as well all
seven law enforcement and one ambulance
uh transports used a combination
restraint all applied before the child
left the sending facility
so those are the summary of year three
on the next page we see the trending
information and I do have a few
highlighted to bring to your attention
first is the average transports per
month between year one and year three we
see a drop from 138 to 106. and this is
complemented by the chart at the bottom
which is the drf transports five report
year which shows you the volume
um by drf and how that has changed and
you can see in year three that across
the board accepting Hampstead Hospital
all the drfs did see a decrease in the
number of patients they've received we
do want to make a point and miss the
point we'll speak more to this but we
want to be clear that this is mostly due
to the reduction in the capacity at the
drfs this is not a reduction in the need
or demand for services in this state
we also see a sharp drop in the number
of children in year three going from 78
to 15. this is related to New Hampshire
hospital no longer receiving children
ieas and again this Lapointe can speak
more to that point
we do see an increase in the use of
restraints so restraints overall Rose
about nine percent between year one and
year three up to from 44 to 53 and I did
highlight the law enforcement using
restraints which jumped about 11 between
year one and year two and then remained
almost exactly the same in year three at
84 percent
and then the final page of the reports
has some trending line graphs the top
chart showing the number of total ieas
per month and you can see that downward
Trend as we spoke about and then the
bottom shows the percentage of
restraints used in transport
um yes and no and you can see how that
fluctuates over the three-year period
and the pages beyond that are an
appendix that provide more detail of the
numbers that went into these statistics
so thank you and let me know if you have
any questions on the data or questions
from what's the point
I have two questions number one in the
chart on the bottom of page six it may
not be longitudinal enough to ask why
the red is going up and the blue is
going down it may not be significant for
thank you representative Pearson
chairman Pearson I was actually
um struck by by that as well and
I think an important point to make is
that obviously the the determination of
utilizing restraints for for
transportation is made by the sending
facility the sending Hospital obviously
also in conjunction with the
transportation that's being provided
whether it be ambulance or law
enforcement so I don't want to speculate
on their rationale behind decision
making but one of the things that struck
me is the timing of this change in the
midst of covid I think covid obviously
can sway some of these percentages and
um I I was wondering if it had to do
with an increase in infection
preventions and safety precautions as it
related to working with these patients
via Transportation but that was a
speculation on my part I think you're
right I don't think that there's enough
data yet to make a solid determination
my second question is where are you
native to
thank you Cleveland Ohio
see if I was to talk about Leos it would
be law enforcement but you spoke so well
I said this one this excuse me you must
any other questions Senator garden thank
you Mr chair
so when we look at law enforcement and
chief you might be able to help us out
here
are those restraints a result of policy
in the department or are these just
reflective of
uh restraints that needed to be applied
because of Behavioral aberrations by the
patients
that's a great question and I would
definitely welcome the chief to join us
if you had more to add but
um I would just reiterate that generally
when the decisions are made to utilize
restraints it's due to the circumstance
or the assessment of the patient at the
time so there are concerns related to
thank you
okay
the chair would like to give a fond
and sad goodbye to Senator gaida and
representative Nelson and representative
soloway and and absencia representative
Marsh for their service on this
committee for the last two years as you
go off into
retirement
what do you hope to do give us about 30
seconds each there you go Mr chairman
since you sit on at least two committees
I chair are you sure you mean that
[Laughter]
I'm signing up for pastoral counseling
okay well I'll book out several hours
representative Nelson what you're going
to do
long list of projects I need to work
and just putting them off
Senator guy the such project lists never
gets shorter right so I um
I fly Indigent remote people to hospital
centers and the group called angel
flights we were part of angel flights
wow and another one Pals yeah uh we
donate our airplanes in our time to take
people that aren't needful of extent
like I go to Presque Isle Maine right
and go to Boston from there I go like
Observer from uh
Montpelier Vermont to New York city so
we provide care for these people
Transportation because either can't
afford it or they're in such a medical
condition that they can't go in County
conveyance wow that's one thing I signed
up to uh take the instruction and the
exams to become a high school baseball
umpire because I love I love baseball
out that the only time
an organist and you know I'm a classical
day trained organist was ever thrown out
of a baseball game was when the it was a
triple A there were three umpires and
they were not calling it right in the
mind of the hometown organist so when
the organists made yet the latest
mistake he broke into a rendition of
three blind mice at which point he was
run the only time in the history of
baseball an organist was ever run by an
Umpire just remember that
well
hi
well it's just
I think it's going to be challenged but
maybe oh well let's fix this but it
doesn't say who's appointing it just
sometimes you have a physician appointed
by